like you like each other no acting
needed here Bruce Willis and Demi Moore
are living breathing proof that you can
be friends with your ex one two three
here we go the two who were married from
1987 to 2000 have been quarantined
together in Idaho since March along with
their three daughters rumors Scout and
Tallulah amid the corona virus pandemic
and on Sunday they celebrated a blended
family Mother's Day with a photo shoot
Demi shared several of the shots on
Instagram
including this one writing thankful to
be with family today and every day
included in the epic family pic Bruce to
me and their girls as well as scout and
Tallulah's boyfriends Bruce's wife Emma
and their two daughters eight-year-old
Mable and six-year-old Evelyn Emma
recently joined Bruce in Idaho after the
die-hard star was separated from his
wife and kiddos due to the pandemic 31
year old rumor wished fans a Happy
Mother's Day to quote from our big ol
mixed family to yours meanwhile 26 year
old Tallulah shared this pic with her
famous mom alongside a heartfelt message
to all the people who might find
Mother's Day to be painful she admitted
she can relate after not talking to her
mom for nearly three years
of course the to put in the work to fix
their relationship and Tallulah says
thankfully three years did not stretch
to forever adding quote I revel in all
that you are to me more and all that you
continue to teach me I think my whole
nature is really all or nothing back in
november demi rumor and Tallulah
appeared on red Tabletalk I felt very
forgotten and I felt like I develop and
I nurtured a narrative that she didn't
love me
and I truly believed it Danny talked
candidly about her past marriage to
Ashton Kutcher suffering a miscarriage
and her struggles with alcohol addiction
something that ultimately put a wedge
between her and her daughter's there
were moments where it would get angry
and I recall being very upset and and
kind of treating her like a child and
speaking to her like a child and kind of
being like you know please like get away
from me and you know she got very angry
and it would happen in front of friends
and it was it was not the mom that we
had growing up directly rumor said she
tried to play peacemaker between her
sisters and their mom but her attempts
backfired scout and Tallulah had very
different experiences than I had when we
stopped talking to my mom they didn't
speak to her for three years I went in
and out as kind of like the ambassador
for the family because at one point her
friends are calling me and being like
I'm really worried about your mom like
you need to talk to her and so then I'm
like okay well like I have to go and fix
this and then my family basically kind
of like shunned me and kind of called me
a traitor for going to talk to her in
January Demi celebrated eight years of
sobriety and her relationship with our
family is back on track Wow why - here
we go
[Music]